pro armenia group is staging a rally
near the white house tonight
urging support for the country in its
fight with azerbaijan over disputed
territory
the u.s france and russia are stepping
up efforts
to get a ceasefire there tonight we have
an exclusive interview with armenia's
president
who is pointing the finger at another
regional player
senior foreign affairs correspondent amy
kellogg reports from milan
italy
it is a long simmering and complex
conflict in a remote corner of the
former soviet union
but suddenly the world has stood up to
listen like never before
it may no longer just be armenians and
azerbaijanis fighting over
nagorno-karabakh
a territory the size of delaware
armenia's president tells fox news
turkey is jumping in and upping the
stakes
it has become a big regional conflict
because turkey has brought with them
also
mujahideens i mean terrorist islamic
terrorists
into azerbaijan even syria has claimed
some of its citizens have headed into
the fray
the senior foreign policy adviser to
azerbaijan's president
denies the allegations any foreigners or
mercenaries we have
quite capable armed forces but russia
and iran have voiced concerns about this
war zone
becoming a magnet for terrorists and are
carefully weighing options
they're all neighbors and azerbaijan
insists turkey
is a good neighbor turkish support to
azerbaijan is a moral
diplomatic and political support
nagorno-karabakh sits within the
national boundaries of azerbaijan but is
populated by armenians
and run practically as its own country
hundreds have been killed in the latest
round of fighting
with each side accusing the other of
carrying out ethnic cleansing
it is ancient land with great cultural
significance
on the edge of an energy-rich region
which is another reason the president of
armenia
is convinced turkey's president wants
inroads they will also have huge
influence on international
energy resources so somehow europe will
become a hostage of turkey
closing or opening the pipelines the
turkish president
voiced full-throated support of
azerbaijan today
accusing the armenians of having a quote
spoiled and uncompromising attitude
this as the u.s france and russia held
urgent talks in geneva
to try to de-escalate a situation that
shows no signs of settling down
brett we'll continue to watch amy thank
you